and so hockey is back and peter you know
we do our draft and we use a trivia
question now to determine
who gets the first pick between you and
sims when it's the three of us so an
important hockey related question today
at the behest of elaine bennis david
putty stopped painting his face before
new jersey devils games he instead
painted his chest what letter did david
putty paint on his chest before the
devil's game peter
d as in dog
there you go but that was i mean that's
ridiculous that was so easy
man david putty was jacked man he was
whoa i didn't realize eat these devils
peter you get the first pick the draft
today the week four goats not in a good
way not the way sims thinks the way you
use it in your column from time to time
but we gotta say it says it all the fact
that you had to clarify what goats are
we it says that you
are dumb that's what it says no all we
talk about is goats all the time and
you're a jerk for saying that okay
so shut up all right
go ahead peter
go to the week
go to the week for me is jared goff he
threw for nine million yards
against the tampa bay buccaneers but
much of that happened because of his own
poor play
you know he gave the uh tampa bay
buccaneers way too many chances made way
too many mistakes and a game that you
should mark down
uh in the win column 10 times out of 10
50 out of 50.
jared goff handed that plus the rams
defense to the bucks on a platter i am
going to argue with that one because
jared goff can't block and throw the
ball at the same time he threw three
interceptions but two of them weren't
his fault so i'm gonna push back against
you i don't like that pick there okay mr
peter king and mister all right i'll
un-go jared goff no
we're stuck with them now okay um all
right i'm gonna go with a unit because
just the unit that we saw have a
performance that i mean i didn't think
would happen anytime soon and it was
shocking but the baltimore ravens
defense i mean they deserve uh you know
the old the goat award the bad goat
award okay because there they were home
football game cleveland browns you know
kind of wobbly we don't know what they
are they're trying to find their
confidence are they battle tested the
ravens can take control as peter
mentioned earlier in the show of the afc
north that they come out with a win
and the ravens defense just got
dominated i mean dominated there's no
other way to say it when you let up over
a hundred something yards to nick chubb
and then of course baker mayfield
through for over 300 yards but
530 total yards of offense by the
cleveland browns yes the ravens get the
bad goat award
all right uh you're going to be shocked
by this one since
cousins
cousins kirk cousins kirk cousins and
kirk cousins we're 20 games into this
experiment now and i think we can safely
declare it to be peter brady's volcano
it is not working and the vikings win
the games are supposed to win but when
it's time to go on the road when it's
time to play in prime time when the
quarterback is conscious of the fact
that he needs to step up and make the
plays he just can't and it was no more
on display than it was at soldier field
on sunday not making the throws that
were there getting criticized by adam
thielen after the game getting called
out sort of by his head coach yesterday
for not pulling the trigger when he
could on the days that they can't run
the ball they need to be able to throw
the ball and they just can't this year
and it all falls to their 84 million
dollar
quarterback kirk cousins sorry kirk yeah
oh yeah you're real sorry i'm sure you
are yeah yeah well he's salty peter his
vikings didn't win or play good he's all
over kirk this week
well he was on he was on my list too so
mike sort of yeah he picked me in front
of me i'm gonna take uh carry on johnson
of the detroit lions and here's why yeah
we're five minutes into the second half
of this game it's a
13-13 game with one of the super bowl
favorites you're playing them great you
have just gone the length of the field
on the kansas city chiefs you're going
to you're going to
find a way to get this one in the end
zone it's going to be 20 to 13. you're
going to be ahead in the third quarter
you're going to ride the wave and you're
going to shock the world and you're
going to beat the chiefs well carry on
johnson
did what you're not supposed to do
unless you're a positive
that you can reach the ball so that it
pierces the plane of the goal he reached
the ball but he was nowhere near the
plane of the goal the ball gets popped
out and the chiefs run it back 100 yards
for the touchdown they end up winning
the game narrowly carry on johnson has
to wear the goat horns for that yeah
that's a really good pick by you peter i
forgot about him uh when i made my
little list here but that was a crucial
part of the football game you were right
and it just wasn't the right opportunity
to do it the way you explained it yeah i
mean there and in the middle of a pile
of people where it's not like it was
just like one guy tackling him where he
could just reach it out he was in the
middle of the mosh pit of a
short-yardage situation and tried to do
it so that was certainly ill-advised
good pick there all right i'm gonna go
with one of my buddies i mean this guy's
my boy blue but josh allen i gotta put
him on the i gotta give him the goat
horns too uh just for
the way he played early in that football
game or not early in that football game
but until he got hurt and i'm i'm i'm
hoping he's okay because you know mike
i'm a big josh allen fan of what he can
do but it was just too loose and
reckless in that game and uh there's
just no no excuse for it you got a great
defense it's the new england patriots in
town and i understand you you want to
have a put on a good show for the
patriots and all that but
man i mean
just the reckless decisions to throw the
ball down into coverage and and you know
the three interceptions and people are
open underneath you know that was just
not a good game by josh allen and he's
got to find a way to reign it in he's
got a little bit of that mike you've
heard me say it it's like every play is
the last play of the football game and
he put them in a tough tough spot and
they were still there to had to be win
the football game and they had a chance
even despite all that but
josh allen got to reign in a little bit
all right i'm going to go with a guy
we've already talked about today and
that is vontez berfit the raiders
linebacker for a variety of reasons for
the unsafe play the potential injury he
could have inflicted on jack doyle the
ejection from the game the raiders still
won but this is a guy that they would
have preferred to have on the field
throughout the course of the game and
now the 12-game suspension who knows
what the ultimate number will be after
appeal but when we talk about the desire
to make the game safer the desire to
make the game more palatable for parents
who are deciding whether or not to let
their children play you cannot play like
vontez perfect you potentially injure
yourself you potentially injure
opponents and you make yourself
unavailable for your team and the
raiders at two and two look look around
a lot of two and two teams in the afc
two and two is the sixth seed right now
based on tiebreakers and the raiders
could use vontez perfect and they may be
without him for the rest of the season
or probably at least half of the rest of
the season all because he continues to
play like an idiot
hard dog yeah my third pick
i mean hey it's
that should be number one on all of our
lists yeah right you're right mike
um
my third pick is gonna be matt ryan
uh because although he didn't do
anything singularly disastrous
it is the point is this
the atlanta falcons come into sunday's
game one and two
you pay your quarterback 30 million
bucks or whatever it is that matt ryan
makes on average per year
and he's got a receiving core of julio
jones calvin ridley mohamed sanu he's
got a healthy devante freeman in the
backfield
he threw the ball 53 times
zero touchdowns 10 points
11 possessions
that is not good enough
and look you can't fire the players you
end up firing the coach and dan quinn my
guess is at the end of this year
probably is gonna get fired but he needs
some help from his players who arthur
blank is paying a jillion dollars to
yeah i'm peter i'm i'm really actually
pissed you did that because that was
going to be my pick i was going to take
the falcons offense and kind of make the
same points you made i mean you're right
i mean hey it's it's just not it's
inexcusable you know some of the
turnovers they had before these games
the matt ryan the red zone interceptions
yeah you know and you're right 10 points
against the tennessee titans defense
that's shown spots of being good don't
don't get me wrong but just not
acceptable with some of the talent they
have and the money they're paying to
some of those guys i'm with you there
okay
i i don't know what that really you
really rattled me there why didn't you
get a passion
that's where i'm going bangles offensive
line that was my next one i'm going
bengal's offensive line because that was
a disaster last night and as you know as
much as i want to say like andy dalton
get out of the pocket a little bit and
have a little more urgency there still i
mean there's no excuse for what we saw
last night and that goes on zach taylor
as well i mean at some point you got to
realize damn we're out man tonight and
our o-line's getting their butt swooped
let's figure out a new formula here to
help uh my quarterback out but you know
just lack of blocking people
as far as picking people up scheme-wise
and then people being picked up but the
guys can't actually execute the blocks
and just getting run over by everybody i
mean tj watt dupreeh casey hayward
stefan tuitt i mean just an embarrassing
performance by that bengals oh line
all right real quickly with my pick and
i'm going off the board a little bit
here technically but i'm going with cam
newton because the video that popped up
friday with the glass of wine and the
cigar and bearing his soul about his
injury look bottom line is you shouldn't
be saying these things publicly because
the the trail of breadcrumbs back to the
panthers hiding that injury concealing
the nature of the injury week one and
week two it's not all that hard to
construct i think the panthers may have
some tough questions to answer with the
league office because of his candor but
also
he had no business playing week one or
week two and who knows whether or not
the panthers would have potentially
beaten the rams or potentially beaten
the buccaneers with kyle allen instead
of cam newton but he should not have
been playing in those games he should
not be telling this stuff to the world
and i know ron rivera is going to tiptoe
around it and say i'm fine with him
being candid i'm fine with him being
honest but
he he bared his soul in a way that
allowed us to realize
selfishness overcame ego overcame what
was best for the team and it was clearly
best for the team based upon what he
admitted in that video friday night that
he should not have been playing week one
and week two and they couldn't have been
any worse than owen two maybe they would
have been one and one and maybe they'd
be three in one right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports